All these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on.
But I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, Keeper4Head, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, 4Head, Swift, Rage, PJ, Salt and Failfish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time.
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, Keeper4Head, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour he calls me.
His doggy emo reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I missed emotes from yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, Keeper4Head, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago...
Twitch emotes from long ago.